[Music]
foreign
so as always at this time of night we do
the Press preview it's our first look at
Sunday's papers and tonight we'll check
out the headlines for the political
correspondent at the guardian I'll leave
the Adu and the format number 10
speechwriter ASA Bennett great to see
you both uh we'll chat here in a moment
after we've had a look at the front
pages that we've got in starting with
the star leading with news of Philip
schofield's departure from this morning
with the headline reading Holly one
Wally zero
the front of the Sunday Mirror leads
with the same story their headline they
think it's all sofa it is now as Phil
stands down from this morning
and ITV we've had our fill reads the
front of the Sunday people
swella tried to cover up speeding
offense reads the front to the mail on
Sunday as there are claims the Home
Secretary may have breached the
ministerial code same story splashed on
the front of the Sunday Times it's
headline bravaman asked civil servants
to help her avoid speeding fine
brexit will be a roaring success the
Sunday Express as an exclusive with the
business secretary if she Jets off on a
one trillion pound trade mission
is your Sunday Telegraph the headline
reading migrations are backs student
visa curbs amid a route over immigration
and as we always remind you you can scan
the QR code that you see on screen join
a program have a look at the front pages
of tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and doing that with me
tonight Alita Adu and ASA Bennett so
let's get cracking and um Elita I don't
know what you think about the the Phil
and Holly Story it's on many of the
front pages especially the tabloids of
course many people will be saying you
know with the cost of living crisis with
war in Ukraine why are we so obsessed
with these two
yeah so they've been the face of you
know morning TV on ITV for decades now
um they've won awards together because
of their intense chemistry and you've
got to remember they find a digestible
way of providing uh needs for people for
families at that time of the day so I
mean they are familiar faces to many
um and it will come of disappointment to
some people others may have seen this
coming for some time given the intense
speculation around their relationship
over the last few weeks you've been
hearing of holy desperate to keep her
job but you know really struggling with
the fact that they're no longer friends
behind the scenes I've been hearing from
all sorts of body language experts
desperate to see if they're any sort of
uh you know visible signs of tension
between the two um on the program but I
think it's just remarkable that given 20
years on this day you know Philip wasn't
given this incredible sender that we'd
usually see on programs like this
instead you know on a sunny afternoon he
dropped a statement must even
um on Twitter or anything he used
Instagram and Instagram story to
highlight the fact that Thursday was his
last show which would be you know
surprising to us all why wasn't he given
that chance let's also say you know
Holly's statements seemed to be quite uh
you know toned down from they say that
she simply said the social will not feel
the same without him that could be for
good or for bad to be honest yeah I mean
her statement was very succinct wasn't
it and Phil's statement didn't even
mention uh Holly
um at all just looking at the front of
the Sunday people Acer TV we've had ITV
we've had our fill and it was a bit more
detail here about perhaps what went
wrong
um ITV bosses told him it was time to go
his fate was sealed at a boss's Summit
on Friday so it would seem that um he
jumped because he was being pushed
yes the the idea basically that he has
been jumped before he was pushed forced
to resign rather than being sacked it's
very much like the politics meets
Showbiz now as we've seen the the couple
were yeah they were fixture at
everyone's TVs it seems for many years
we've seen them on this morning we used
to see them on dancing on ice and you
know Phil had all sorts of shows yeah I
think I remember the cube and other
things he'd do on this morning
um the highlights low lights they range
from uh you know if memory serves you
know when he came out and was
interviewed by Holly
um in a very emotional chat on the this
morning sofa
um to more controversial ones like when
he was talking to David Cameron
um and I received to recall that at that
time there's all sorts of allegations
about Lord McAlpine because he basically
didn't wave the list of names that he
thought because he'd just done some
research on the internet prime minister
he said and had shown these names of
people who were the social media thought
were you know suspect alleged child
abusers and the names could be seen on
camera you know so it was very sort of
awkward clunky but you know oh you had
to see it my God what live TV that was
you know amid all these travails then to
absolutely go down in the Flames like
this where you've had days of
bloodletting it seems in the media you
know briefing and cat fights it seems
you know I think there's sources telling
her one paper the other day that you
Phil was like the Grim Reaper and that
Holly was saying it was either you know
her or him that has to go so clearly you
know the papers are very pro-holy now
because she is the Survivor yeah and uh
Elita just a a final thought on this
really just having a look at the daily
The Daily Star Holly won Wally nil
um it certainly seems as if uh the
papers verdict is that Holly is going to
come out of this far better than uh
Phillip Schofield although he uh has
been told that he's still got a new
Prime Time show coming up he's
presenting the soap Awards next week I
think in terms of ITV how how do they
manage this from now on their crisis
management hasn't been brilliant up
until this point because as you say
there's been so much speculation over
recent weeks in the papers now this
bombshell has dropped where does ITV go
from here
yes well I mean earlier today we heard
from the likes of Eamon Holmes he was
also a familiar faced on this day before
Holly and Phil took over and he was sort
of insisting that this program is an
institution and it will survive even if
both of those presenters went because
people loved the show and regardless you
know of which incredible Faith decides
to come into the into the program people
will always tune in because it's
something that they will do it's part of
their lives it's part of their routines
but I think ultimately as as appointed
it seems as though the paper is at least
the tabloids have gone on the side of
Holly she has been it seems as though
she was uh the victim quite like the
nasty briefing earlier this year when
she was forced to take a brief Break
um apparently due to an illness and it
seemed as though the sources are
claiming that
um still seem to sort of highlight an
illness that she was going through which
was completely unnecessary and quite a
violating of her privacy and it seems as
though from that point Thomas is earlier
this year tensions really started to
Flame
um but ultimately you know the question
is you know are people really that into
the sort of breakfast TV couple do
people really see this as something that
they need to carry on with going forward
on television or will this will this
episode with this sargo and itvc the
downfall of such programs and possibly a
move into something else we'll have to
see yeah we will have to see won't we
um okay so let's move on to the mail on
Sunday picture of Philip and Holly on
the front there in fact with your TV
shirt that you're wearing tonight so
maybe you should think about an audition
for the sofa who knows I was trying to
pitch I thought I just you know soft
soap this see if everyone get ideas well
I think it's working I think it's
working
um you talked about Showbiz and politics
let's move on to politics
um and I think two papers both seem to
be claiming this as an exclusive um
we've got the mail little front page
here suela try to cover up speeding
offense now she the allegation here is
that she asked officials to set up a
private driving awareness course after
she was caught for speeding she clearly
didn't want to be seen with members of
the public
yes and uh it is there are questions now
flying about whether she may have been
broken the ministerial code because
ministers are not meant to have civil
servants you know get their hands dirty
in helping resolve ministers uh personal
affairs
um and in particular the report suggests
that as a result of not getting the
officials to do this she then may have
had it resolved more privately her
political AIDS do you look into this
um it is also interesting to note then
that it has been reported previously
that she's asked you she was said to
other MPS to have asked whether you
could claim your speeding fines on
expenses
um so basically the knives do seem to be
out they do seem to be being sharpened
for the home of secretary
um and I think it may well be to do with
the fact that she's giving very
bombastic speeches in Immigration she
did earlier this week at a national
conservatism Summit and so I think some
people in the party you know they
clearly have their interests in trying
to stoke the waters other front pages
I'll quickly just add they're also
talking about Rouse on migration policy
how do you actually get net migration
numbers down
um and so you know clear there is some
you know a lot of people yeah I think
other quarters of government will be
rubbing their hands you're with Glee on
reading these headlines as well of as
you're speaking uh Acer the home office
have just issued a statement or
certainly a spokesperson for the Home
Secretary saying Miss bravaman accepts
that she was speeding last summer and
regrets doing so she took the three
points and paid the fine last year uh as
simple as that Aletha what are your
thoughts about this
interesting that this saw us close to
the Home Secretary didn't dispute the
fact that she had asked civil servants
to get involved and try their best to
avoid her being seen by members on the
public which would have been extremely
embarrassing for her but ultimately
would have proven that she had done the
fine and was doing the time in that sort
of sense
um but the liberal Democrats and the
labor party are now calling for an
investigation and urging the prime
minister's ethics advisor to really find
out if he has broken the ministerial
code because you know this isn't right
for members of public life to be getting
people who are meant to be politically
Mutual to do some sort of cover-up in
this sense
um but as as I said you know uh the Home
Secretary has been subject to a lot of
criticism this week and this is just
another nice going into the back
ultimately there are cabinet ministers
you know within the Mrs cnx team
questioning what why the Prime Minister
doesn't have enough of a grip on her you
know he seems to be letting her loose
and she's making all sorts of ludicrous
crimes on migration at Summits like the
national con conference earlier this
week but ultimately this has been you
know subject to you know her comments
and migration rather you know with
members calling calling out her racist
rhetoric previously and like the fact
that she's sort of freelancing on what
number 10 believes in terms of migration
has been subject to intense scrutiny and
I think after the wake of these two
stories that were both obtained by both
papers I must say sometimes papers do
share
um excuses in this format
um is giving Tory MPS who aren't happy
with her stance and migration another
chance to call for her resignation for
example
okay all right we will leave that one
there thank you both for the moment
coming up after the break we'll take a
look at some more of tomorrow's papers
including this story on the front of the
Sunday Telegraph that stand with
migration theme migrations are backs
student visa curves is what the sunny
Telegraph have gone with talk about that
and more next
[Music]
welcome back part two of The Press
preview uh the political correspondent
at the guardian Elita Abu is here and
also former limited speechwriter ASA
Bennett Acer front of the telegraph um
tell us about this story migrations are
back student visa curbs
yes this report drills down into the
seeding row uh blazing at the heart of
the government
um in which as we know one of Rishi
sunak's big priorities is to to tackle
the channel boats Crisis get a grip on
migration and given that figures kind of
suggest that the the latest migration
stats could suggest as soon as next week
that yeah there'll be a net increase of
700 700 000 you know putting us well on
track towards a million
um then you know this is not going to go
away now admittedly the reason that we
will be seeing record highs in net
migration is somewhat influenced you
know and beefed up by the inflows of a
refugees from Hong Kong we've been
allowing uh you know fleeing Chinese
repression and also Ukrainian refugees
of course
um but at the same time it does cut down
to the old yeah balance of you know how
to what extent do you then crack down in
border control well there are ideas
coming from the head of the migration
advisory committee namely he lands on
the idea of The Graduate visas the the
basically there is a risk he argues from
Sunday Telegraph that people come for
two years they over stay perhaps they
didn't slip into low-skilled work so
then maybe there's work there in terms
of cracking down on that section
um with the time will tell given that
the treasury is known and reported to be
resistant to this along with the
business department
um and so this is General tussle of on
the one hand here the people that sort
of brow from the Home Secretary is very
much all systems go Keen to crack down
on this area and more
um and to how supporters would say that
if you don't you are doing the economy
to very much low growth low skills by
continuing to rely on cheap labor so
this argument is going to run yeah Alita
as ASA was alluding to there there are
splits on there not only in in the Tory
party as a whole but also in the cabinet
yes absolutely and you know we are
waiting for it all important all
important announcements that's come
later this week
um I think you know the problem is Rishi
cynic has made this an incredible
priority migration you know cutting it
down legally and illegally essentially
um with this story Professor Brian Bell
is essentially saying the scheme has
been abused
um he claims that foreign students have
been getting unrestricted rights to work
and almost they've been getting a
two-for-one sort of deal that you know
they can also get one year of a Masters
program but also be able to bring their
dependents and spouses with them and
work for an extra two years which has
caused concern to him and others that
work with him on the advisory committee
um he's claiming that the government
were warned about this five years ago so
I guess questions have been raised to
know why the government hasn't acted on
this stina
um you know apparently the the story
also cites figures claiming that foreign
graduate students have dependents in
this country have risen from 16
000 in 2018 to 135
000 backing the argument in this paper
that would you know arguably uh call for
migration to be restricted naturally but
also that it starts facts that there are
73 000 students that are on visas now so
they're claiming these generous rules
really need to be curbed sooner rather
than later and it must be said that this
argument you know has notoriously been
brewing since Rishi
um came into cabinet around November I
believe ministers with floating ideas on
trying to buy any any sort of foreign
student hadn't had a degree at a top
university whether that be Oxbridge or
maybe the top five universities in the
country but again we'll have to see how
this plays out
um I just want to squeeze One More Story
and actually it's all so on the front of
the Sunday Telegraph Acer noisy heat
pumps
yes um it turns out that the saviors of
the environment that have been much
vetted with by supporters and they will
be as noisy as fridges and given how
Keen the government is to try and have
us all store them on the back of our
houses then officials will be doing lots
of work to work out if actually it's you
know too noisy because if you imagine
having loads of those in neighborhoods
you're perhaps all build up to a
cumulative effect like having because of
someone Drilling in there you know in
your backyard so
um you know let's see what happens with
the research obviously it's for those
who are skeptical about these devices
they will find even more evidence but
then you know obviously these things
aren't silent maybe someone will invent
silent heat pumps give them time